Revisamos el tiempo todos los días, a lo largo del día,
pero alguna vez te has preguntado ¿de dónde viene tomar el tiempo?
¿Por qué es importante saber qué hora es?
¿Quién definió el reloj?
y ¿por qué caramba existen tantos husos horarios diferentes?
La primer forma para medir el tiempo fue con el reloj de sol
y los primeros relojes solares de los que se tiene recolección
son los obeliscos que datan desde hace 5 mil años.
Los relojes solares indican el tiempo proyectando una sombra
sobre una superficie.
El objeto que proyecta la sombra es un palo colocado en el centro llamada gnomon.
Un reloj solar bien construido puede medir el tiempo con gran precisión,
inclusive se usaron para monitorear el funcionamiento de los relojes hasta la era moderna.
Pero los relojes solares tienen sus limitaciones.
Necesitan que el sol brille,
por lo tanto no funcionan de noche cuando está obscuro.
Muchos dispositivos han sido usados con el paso del tiempo para estimar el paso del tiempo:
por ejemplo velas y baras de incienso que se consumen a una velocidad estimada,
usadas junto con el reloj de arena.
Los relojes de arena contienen arena muy fina
que pasa por un orificio a una velocidad constante
e indica un periodo de tiempo determinado por el paso de la arena a través de éste.
El origen del reloj de arena es incierto,
aunque a comienzos del sigo XIV, el reloj de arena era comúnmente usado
especialmente a bordo de los barcos.
El movimiento del barco no afectaba al reloj de arena,
a diferencia de otros dispositivos.
El reloj mecánico fue inventado en el siglo XIII,
lo que desató un gran cambio en la manera de medir el tiempo.
El reloj moderno se basó en el balanceo de un péndulo
o la vibración de un cristal de quarzo, que era mucho más preciso que un reloj de arena
o las velas.
Hoy, la base del tiempo científico
es un conteo continuo de segundos
basado en relojes atómicos alrededor del mundo, conocido como Tiempo Atómico Internacional.
¿Por qué es importante medir el tiempo?
El tiempo regula nuestra vida diaria
y hace posible que nos comuniquemos con otros de manera precisa
alrededor del mundo.
Sin un sistema tendríamos problemas con el cultivo,
las estructuras sociales, las comunicaciones y los negocios.
Tomemos como ejemplo el sistema ferroviario estadounidense.
A mediados del siglo XIX, cada ferrocarril usaba su propio horario
basado generalmente en la hora local de la oficina central,
y los horarios de los trenes se publicaban usando su propio horario.
Algunas de los cruces de carriles más importantes
servían a diferentes ferrocarriles,
y tenían un reloj para cada ferrocarril, cada uno con su diferente huso horario.
La distancia entre Nueva York y Boston es de 2 grados, u 8 minutos,
lo cual puede hacer la diferencia entre llegar o perder la conexión de tren.
Si la diferencia entre Nueva York y Boston
es de 8 minutos, imagina la diferencia
entre Boston y Australia.
Los husos horarios nivelan estas diferencias
y hacen las comunicaciones mucho más sencillas.
Un huso horario es una región en la tierra
que tiene un tiempo estándar uniforme.
Existen 40 husos horarios en la tierra,
porque del huso más temprano al más tarde
hay 26 horas de diferencia.
Cualquier fecha del calendario existe en algún punto
del planeta por 50 horas.
Así que la próxima vez que alguien te pregunte
¿Qué hora es?
Tu respuesta podría ser mucho más complicada de lo que solía ser.